[Music]
XCOM chimera squad is a brand-new
turn-based tactics game in the acclaimed
XCOM series in XCOM two players led the
resistance against the alien rulers of
earth and their puppet government five
years later
earth is liberated and humans and aliens
must forge an uneasy peace welcome to
city 31 where former combatants live
side by side with unity hanging in the
balance this game follows chimera squad
an elite team of human and alien agents
chosen for their abilities and
dedication sent to help secure city 31
chimera squads success will keep the
city safe but their failure will mean
renewed violence
at the heart of the game our chimera
squads tactical operations where the
agents respond to combat in the city
each of these battles are divided into
encounters
[Music]
breach mode is a key new feature to
combat this phase begins each encounter
and allows you to choose chimera squads
entry points and agent turn order first
in get the drop on enemies and unleash
devastating special abilities
the tactical choices you make during a
breach can set the tone for the entire
encounter will you head to cover or
engage the targets where agents operate
solo or work together do you concentrate
fire on the most threatening enemy or do
you try to take down multiple future
targets first either way don't expect to
clear an entire room during the breach
face some encounters have multiple
breach points to choose from each with
distinct advantages and disadvantages
some breach points are only accessible
by specific agent abilities for
equipment
all units turns are interleaved which
means that chimera squad agents and
enemies alternate turns in single
timeline turn order is an important
aspect of your tactical plan knowing
which enemy and agent will act next will
be crucial in dealing with threats this
timeline presents new opportunities some
agents and enemies who change units
places in the timeline chimera squad has
an ability called team up once
permission you can choose a member of
your squad to jump right to the top of
the turn order this can allow you to get
an agent to safety or to get the drop on
an enemy
agents who take a beating and lose all
their hit points start bleeding out
another agent must then stabilize their
ally stabilized agents remain
unconscious for the restavek if an agent
bleeds out entirely the mission fails
and must be restarted
keeping your agents healthy and in the
field is critical as agent abilities
synergize with each other in different
ways each agent has a unique set of
skills that they can bring to the team
some agents can destroy an enemy's cover
to give the rest of the squad a better
chance to hit other agents can forcibly
move units with triggering and allies
over launch or pulling
some agents can even shield a teammate
equipment can provide additional
abilities to any agent the unique and
varied skills of primary squad will
provide endless opportunities for
tactician ups every mission begins and
ends at HQ your hub for all operations
new missions and their potential rewards
can be viewed in the city map chimera
squad can embark on some missions
immediately investigations can speed
progress towards critical missions some
missions may not have the most
tantalizing rewards but need to be
prioritized for other reasons like
lowering the level of unrest each
district in the city has its own unrest
score if any district score maxes out
the unrest of the entire city will rise
if overall city unrest reaches a
critical level Chimera Squad will fail
their campaign in the model city of
unification will be consumed in chaos
and violence
promote any agents who ranked up during
their last encounter in the armory
promotions give agents new abilities to
use in the field you can also adjust
their equipment here
stock up on er equipment hit supply and
the scavengers market supply is always
open for business but lacks some of the
more exotic goods the scavengers market
is known to offer
however the scavengers market only opens
occasionally and may not always be
around when you need it at the assembly
you can create items and upgrades for
sale at the store you'll need to
research patterns before you can build
them if you want to avoid being down an
agent mid mission you can build androids
to fill in for unconscious allies you
can upgrade these androids and change
their equipment but they don't have
special abilities if an agent is
critically wounded they may develop a
scar which will lower a key stat
assigning an agent to training will
repair the scar if you can afford to
have the agent out of commission for a
few days
training can give an uninjured agent
improved stats or even new abilities
SpecOps can be used to send a single
agent out to gain resources or for other
strategic goals like lowering the level
of unrest in various districts of city
thirty-one
hi Mara squad must prevent an arc at all
costs city 31 is the first step toward a
unified future Allah is riding on the
shoulders of chimeras
a lot is riding on
[Music]
you